oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith
after this infamous moment will smith
was asked to leave the oscar ceremony
this according to a new statement from
the academy and the letter announces
that quote disciplinary proceedings are
underway following the king richard
starr's altercation with chris
rocks that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay multiple violations of
the academy standards of conduct are
cited quote inappropriate physical
contact threatening behavior and
compromising the integrity of the
academy
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees the statement ends with a
revelation quote we would like to
clarify that mr smith was asked to leave
the ceremony and refused the academy
adds quote we also recognized we could
have handled the situation differently
the letter also takes a moment to
address chris directly quote mr rock we
apologize to you for what you
experienced on our stage and thank you
for your resilience in that moment
while it's unclear at what point will
was asked to leave here's what we do
know this is a long time well i think a
long time coming for him and it's a lot
of emotion and it's probably all welling
up in him right now following the
incident itsy learned that denzel
washington and tyler perry stepped in
pulling wool aside for a private chat
during the commercial break after
winning an oscar for best actor the
smith family hit up the star-studded
vanity fair party trophy in hand that's
will wrapping summertime for the
gathered crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
an eyewitness at the party tells e.t
will was quote acting as though nothing
happened earlier
the source adds quote everyone was
pretty much ignoring the entire
situation including will
what were your thoughts
i thought it was a joke at first
elsewhere at the bash reactions were
mixed among celebrities
you know i would like to more of a
straight apology
to chris i thought will's performance
was amazing and i'm sorry that he
tarnished it with this behavior i've
seen a man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
they put her face up on the screen
looked over at his wife she was hurt
and e.t is learning more about will's
mindset in the aftermath a source tells
us quote will does not regret sticking
up for jada but he does have remorse for
how he went about it he acted out of
impulse there's also will's formal
apology on monday quote i would like to
publicly apologize to you chris i was
out of line and i was wrong i'm
embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be
ask for jada whose face said it all jada
i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see
it all right
our source says jada is quote glad that
will stood up for her because she was
hurt by the joke the red table talk host
broke her silence on tuesday sharing
this message to instagram quote this is
a season for healing and i'm here for it
[Music]